نبقى في عالم الموسيقى وينضم الينا في
الاستوديو استوديو صباح العربيه الفنان
اسامه الرحباني منورنا طول عمرك اهلا فيكم
انتم اللي منورين
معك النجاح الدائم احنا سمعنا كليب عن من
شباب بيتخيلوا عالم الموسيقى بعد 20 عام
يعني هم شباب من عمر العشرين يمكن سمعت
مقتطفات منه انت برايك يعني كيف راح يكون
او يتغير عالم الموسيقى من وجهه نظر
الشباب هلا ما في شك الفنون بحد ذاتها
تطورها كان كتير كبير خصوصا 20 لكن كمان
فينا نعتبر انه على جميع الحقول الفنيه
اصطدمت نوعا ما يعني مع تطور دالي وبيكاسي
وبعدين التجارب ما بتخلص او بالموسيقى
الكلاسيكيه ان كان
اصطدمت كمان بنوع من التجارب الموسيقى
الكلاسيكيه وايضا الموسيقى المودرن دخلنا
كمان هموم الناس اللي بنسميهم اكثر نحن
صارت الراب مثلا يلي دخل العربي مثلا ودخل
على اوروبا كتير وصار اذا بدك نمبر وان
بسموه يعني اللي بالضواحي عند الناس اللي
عندهم مشاكل للمهاجرين من المغارب المغرب
العربي او افريقيا او العرب يعني بتحسيهم
دخلت فيهم اكثر مسيطره اكثر رح يضل في
موسيقى من كل الانواع لكن اهم شيء انا
اللي بدي اقوله انه نحن كمجتمع عربي
نحصن اولادنا اتجاه الانتقاء الجيد للمصير
الجيده يعني بكل شيء في حلو بيقولوا لك
انت شو بتحب اي جمال السمراء او الشقراء
او الصفراء او الهنديه او الجمال جمال ما
له حدود ما له نسب وين مكان هو حلو بعدين
مثل ما بقولوا بيوتي اس يعني كل انسان
عنده فكره العين انه هي اللي بتشوف
الاشياء لكن نحن وجبنا واجب العالم العربي
وواجب الاعلام وكل الناس اللي بتشتري
باعلام تدويق يعني اضاءه اكثر الفنون
الجيده لانه هديك قادره توصل بالسوشيال
ميديا بشكل كثير كبير نحن بنعرف بمصر شو
عم تواجه مشاكل مثلا ما بقولوا الناس
اغاني المهرجانات او اغاني اللي هي موجوده
لانه هجوم او التراث القديم
مش غلط الواحد يقدر يستمعي وكل شيء بس مشي
تصير التعميم هو المشكله لازم يكون في نوع
من الانتقاء
لانه حضرتك ذكرت اغاني المهرجانات لانه
فعلا عليها جدل كبير في مصر لكن ازاي
نرتقي بالضوء لانه في النهايه فن
المهرجانات اصبح محبب لكل الشرائح حتى في
مصر وفي الدول العربيه ما في شك انه حسب
المجتمع وتركيبته لمن الشراء يعني خلينا
نكون واضحين يعني المجتمعات الاوروبيه
تستوعب الموسيقى مثلا المتعدده اكثر يعني
الكلاسيكيه او البوب
اكثر من المجتمعات اللي نوعا ما عندها نمط
معين من الاشياء هلا شو بيستجد عليها ليه
بدك تشوفي من ورا مشاكل اقتصاديه من وراء
خفه ثقافه من ورا التربيه من ورا التوجه
الاعلامي ما هو كمان مشكله بس ما ننسى نحن
انه سوشيال ميديا انتم ببيتك فيك تنزلي
على التلفزيون معين على اليوتيوب تحط اللي
بدك اياه يعني هون المشكله انه صار صحيح
تكنولوجيا بتفيد من المال لكن بتضر من مال
بتسهل عمليه انك تعدب بيتك وتبسي اللي بدك
اياه بس كمان خلقت انه كل انسان صفى دكتور
وناقض ومهندس ومحامي وخبير زليزل
اراء وبيشتم وبيرخص المستوى الفكري لاي
انسان مشكله خطر انه مين ما كان صار
وعلى مستوى لا في مستوى اخلاقي ولا يعني
عم نزل كل المستويات الاتي اعظم من هون
انا بطلب من الناس او خلينا الوزارات مع
الوزاره التربيه والثقافه وكل التوجيه
نلهمني حصنوا واولادهم المدارس حسن
الاولاد انه مش كل شيء على السوشيال ميديا
صح مش كل شيء على السوشيال ميديا مسموح مش
كل واحد بقول موال بيحطوا على السوشيال
ميديا وبيشتم الثاني في اشياء عندها مستوى
يعني في ترخيص بدي اسال على موضوع النقله
في عالم الموسيقى
نتحدث عن المستقبل عن عشر سنين الى الامام
عشرين سنه يعني في الماضي انتقلنا من عصر
اغنيه ساعه ونص الى اغنيه الربع ساعه ثم
من ربع ساعه الى الخمس دقائق علما زمان
اغنيه الساعه ما كنا نمل منها اليوم اغنيه
الخمس دقائق احيانا بتمل منها صوره بسبب
الهبوط اللي حصل بس شو بتتوقع للمستقبل
يعني الاستهلاك هو على جميع الاصعده موجود
يعني التجاره موجوده الاعلام بقول لك انه
اذا بتعملها اقل من ثلاث دقائق ويكون عظيم
اذا بتعمليها دقيقتين ونص عظيم لا تيقطع
الكليب ونطلع مصاري اكتر يعني كله له
علاقه بالبزنس بزنس عم تتحكم بالفنون
لهالب لازم يكون في من كل الاشياء لكن
كمان هل انه فقط الفن هو للتسليه ولا بده
يكون عنده رساله معينه هل الاعلام مش
واجبه انه هو يرتقي بالشعوب والمجتمعاته
لانه بيدخل على البيوت الناس على افكار
الناس مش واجبه انه يرتقي بالناس وبالعالم
وهو يكون مربي صالح لحتى يخلي هالناس لكن
هذا الاساس نرجع على المدارس لحتى نقدر
نحن نعمل يعني متار تعمر بنايه بتعمرها
بجمعتين بس جيل ما فيك تعمره الا بعشرين
سنه هو تربيه ابنك عم تربيه انت 17 سنه
كيف تطعميه كيف تهتم فيه كيف بتعلمه وكيف
بتاخدوا يلعب كيف يحترم الاشخاص هلا صارت
مع كل شي مفتوح بالسوشيال ميديا كل الناس
عايشه على هايبر والقدرانين عالي وما
بيحترموا الاكبر منهم يعني كل هالاشياء
الي علاقه بالتطور العصر الضاغط بالمناسبه
بما انه حضرتك بتتكلم عن السوشيال ميديا
هل ظهور المنصات كان في صالح الموسيقى
فرائك هيك وهيك خليني اقول لك برجع بقول
لك انا التكنولوجيا سهلت كتير لاي انسان
جاهل انه يعمل موسيقى دون معرفه شو هي
الموسيقى
والناس المتلقي اذا شافها لقطه الغنيه ما
بيعرف الواحد كيف ترجع الغنيه بينبسط فيها
وهو بصدق حاله من مال بصير شوف حاله انه
هو عظيم بنفس الوقت الناس من ميله عم
يشتغلوا بهالنقطه
اشياء كل يوم نحن عم نتلاقى كتير من
الاغاني او حتى في شغله بترخصه بتوصلي
بتسهلي عند الناس بتوصل لعند الناس هي هيك
بكل شيء بالمجتمعات انه يعني سهل انك تقول
خليني اقول بدك تعملي تلفه النظر لكل
العالم تحكي عني بتقوم بتعملي حركه عكس
المجتمع اذا واحد شلح كل ثيابه مشي على
الطريق كل امريكا بتحكي عنه كل العالم
بتحكي عنه خالف تعرف شغله موجوده عند كل
العالم والتفكير لكن المشكله هي انه ادانا
احنا بدنا نكون عنا قوه لحتى نقدر نضلنا
نقبل الاشياء الجيده والاشياء لا بدنا
نعمل وقفه
كمان من مملكه بصمه فيه
[موسيقى]
طبعا
طويله
بدي اشكر ماريو بدي اشكر رافي اللي هم
اصدقاء ونشتغل مع بعض دائما ورافي رافقنا
بالفرقه كل الوقت الجلد بالكونسرت ومن اهم
العازفين بالعالم العربي
متشكر جدا سريع بس احنا تكلمت عن طريق
استهلاك الموسيقى يعني من الايام الشريط
الكاسيت والسي دي الى
الشركات وصار في استحواذات وصار في تغيرات
حتى مشاكل وخلافات بين الفنانين والراكت
كيف تشوف هذا الشيء يعني راح يكون
امريكا واوروبا ماشيين مثل السهم الصريح
كتير بخصوص كل شيء في اسمه قوانين العلاقه
كل يوم بيطلع عليها من تحميل ومن الاشياء
الرقميه وشو حقوق وشو محقوق شو بيطلع له
للانسان للاسف العالم العربي كثير بعيد عن
الحقوق الملكيه الفكريه وخصوصا انه لبنان
من الناس الاساسيه بهال- بينتبهوا على
الاساس هاي الشغله وكوني انا رئيس جمعيه
المؤلفين الملحنين ببيروت
مجلس مؤلفين وملحنين بعيني هالنقطه كثير
مع كثير الناس لانه المفروض يكون في حقوق
للمؤلف والملحن لكن في انه برا الحقوق كل
لحظه مثل البركان عم تغلي عم يجددوا كل
يوم للاسف كثير كثير بعيد العالم العربي
ما بيعرف انه اهم شيء هلا بالعالم الغربي
هو اسمه الانترتايموند المحامين اهم
محامين واغلى محامين بامريكا صاروا
في اشياء رقميه صفى المصارع عم يطلعوا
بسرعه عندهم غليو المحامين
انه فيها الجو يلي بيغني بالعالم
العربي متخبط بس انه نهتم بالزعماء
بالسياسيين وما بنخبر الا بنستضيف هيدا
بيشتم هيدا بلبنان عم بعطي مثل هذا
التلفزيون هذا يشتم هيدا هم ما بيشكلوا
شيء لانه بعد خمسين سنه انت ما بتذكري الا
بيتهوفن وموزار وشكسبير
وفيروز وام كلثوم وعبد الوهاب ما بتذكري
حدا حولهم مين كان اذا حلوا بقى الاعلام
يقول لنا حلو شوي ريحونا من الشحن السياسي
والضغط وين المكان اينما بتروحي بالعالم
العربي يعني شكرا لوجودك معنا بالاستوديو
الفنان اسامه الرحباني عاده حديثك لا يمال
لولا سيف الوقت يعني شكرا لوجودك معنا